[موسيقى]
مساؤكم واهلا بكم الى التاسعه هذا المساء
وهذه عناويتها
الرئيس السوري يتراس وفد بلاده لقمه جده
بعد 12 عاما من الانقطاع عن القمم العربيه
يقود مسيره الاعلام وسط القدس والامن
الاسرائيلي يعتقل عشرات الفلسطينيين
[تصفيق]
على تمثيل الجمهوريين واستطلاعات الراي
تعيد بايدن للمنافسه
ولايه مونتانا تحضر تطبيق التواصل
الاجتماعي الصيني تيك توك بالكامل
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء وصل الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد الى مدينه جده للمشاركه
في اعمال الدوره الثانيه وثلاثين الاجتماع
مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه على مستوى القمه
وكان الاسد اكد ان انعقاد القمه العربيه
في السعوديه سيعزز العمل العربي المشترك
لتحقيق تطلعات الشعوب العربيه
[موسيقى]
وفي مقابله مع العربيه قال معاون وزير
الخارجيه السوري ايمن سوسان قال ان سوريا
لم تغب عن الجامعه العربيه بل ان التحديات
والظروف هي من فرضت عليها الغياب
سوريا لم تغب عن الجامعه العربيه او عن
العرب لتعود اليهم سوريا حره دائما وكلمات
جميع من
الوفود العربيه بالامس تحدثت عن هذا
الحضور الدائم لسوريا في الوجدان العربيه
هناك ظروف
فرضت هذا الشيء ربما يكون علينا جميعا
اما العوده
لا اعتقد ان المصطلح هو صحيح المهم اليوم
نحن مع بعض هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي علينا
كعرب ان نكون مع بعض لان في ذلك الخلاص
لنا ما شهدته دولنا خلال 12 سنه الماضيه
يثبت هذا الشيء الشرور التي احاطت ببعض
الدول العربيه انعكست على الجميع وبالتالي
انعكست على الواقع العربي كان الواقع
العربي غير صار فاصبح واقعا ماسويا
[موسيقى]
اذا عوده سوريا الى المشهد العربي
والاقتتال في السودان والعديد من الملفات
والقضايا تستعد القمه العربيه ثانيه
وثلاثون في جده لمناقشتها الزميل عبد
الرحمن العصيمي رصد لنا ابرزها في هذا
التقرير نتابع
ملفات ساخنه وتحديات عده تواجه القمه
العربيه الثانيه 32 في مدينه جده التي
تاتي في ظل ظروف امنيه معقده تمر بها
المنطقه العربيه والعالميه على حد سواء ما
ابرزوا هذه الملفات ملف الازمه السودانيه
من ابرز الملفات المطروحه على طاوله القمه
العربيه وسط توقعات بتحرك عربي واسع
لانهاء حاله الاقتتال استكمالا للدوري
السعودي القائم حاليا عمليه السلام في
اليمن واتمامها ستكون من اولويات القمه
العربيه حيث من المتوقع ان يكون هناك دعم
عربي للتوافق اليمني المنبثقي من الاتفاق
السعودي اليمني لتحقيق الاستقرار الدائم
في البلاد ايضا من ابرز ملفات المطروحه في
قمه جده عوده سوريا الى الحضن العربي وتع
اعاده دمجها في المشهد العربي عبر اطلاق
مبادرات وتوصيات مرتقبه في بيان القمه
الختامي الامن الغذائي هو الاخر يعتبر من
الملفات المشتركه على اجنده القمه العربيه
ما يستدعي ضروره تحقيق السله الغذائيه
الواحده التي تحقق الاكتفاء الذاتي للعرب
بحسب الخبراء الامن المائي كذلك ياتي ضمن
ابرز ملفاته قمه جدا لا سيما في ظل
النزاعات الاقليميه الراهنه سواء مرتبطه
في السودان ومصر مع اثيوبيا او في سوريا
والعراق مع تركيا ملفات اخرى سيناقشها
الزعماء العرب في قمتهم 32 الاوضاع
السياسيه في ليبيا ودعم الجهود لتحديد
موعد للانتخابات بالاضافه الى النهوض
بالعمل العربي المشترك ووضع اليه الزاميه
لتطبيق ومتابعه مخرجات قرارات القمه
العربيه
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مدينه جده العربيه
[موسيقى]
وقبل وصول الاسد بدات مدينه جده استقبال
عدد من الرؤساء العرب تحضيرا لانعقاد
القمه يوم غد ستشهد جده عدد من اللقاءات
الجانبيه التي تجمع عدد من قاده وزعماء
دول العربيه على هامش القمه الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي كان اول الواصلين الى
جده للمشاركه في القمه العربيه في دورتها
32 وينتظر بدء توافد قاده دول العربيه
تبعا الى جده
[موسيقى]
الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه وتحديدا في البلده
القديمه في القدس حيث اندلعت مواجهات بين
فلسطينيين واسرائيليين على هامش مسيره
الاعلام بالمدينه فيما شنت القوات
الاسرائيليه حمله اعتقالات بحق فلسطينيين
قالت انهم يخططون للقيام بعمل عنف هذا
وكثفت الشرطه الاسرائيليه من تواجدها على
طول خط سير المسيره التي يشارك فيها عدد
من الوزراء والمسؤولين الاسرائيليين من
بينهم وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن كثير
[موسيقى]
هذا واظهرت صور اعتداء الشرطه الاسرائيليه
على الفلسطينيه والصحفيين في البلده
القديمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبل ان اذهب الى اخبار السودان هذه
الخارجيه السودانيه تبلغ حكومه جنوب
السودان احتجاجها على زياره موسى
اذا في جديد اخبار السودان وفيما يتعلق
بالوضع الانساني شخص من كل ثلاثه سودانيين
كان يعتمد على المساعدات الانسانيه حتى
قبل انزلاق الحرب وبعد شهر على بدء
الاقتتال حذرت الامم المتحده من انها 25
مليون شخص اي اكثر من نصف سكان السودان
بحاجه الى مساعدات انسانيه وللحمايه وقدرت
احتياجات السودان الانسانيه باكثر من
ثلاثه مليارات دولار من ضمنها ما يقارب
470 مليون دولار اضافيه لمساعده نحو مليون
لاجئ فرو من البلاد ليرتفع بذلك حجم
المساعدات المطلوبه من مليار وسبعمائه
وخمسين مليون دولار في ديسمبر الماضي الى
مليارين و600 مليون ستسمح ايضا هذه
الاموال لهيئات الاغاثه بالوصول الى 18
مليون شخص يعدون الاكثر عرضه لل داخل
البلاد كل ذلك بحسب مدير مكتب الامم
المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه في جنيف
[موسيقى]
شبيه ترامب او من وصف بالوحش الذي صنعه
رئيس الامريكي السابق قد يصارعه فعلا على
عرينه فحاكموا فلوريدا روندي سانتوس سيعلن
ترشيحه لسباق رئاسي رسميا الاسبوع المقبل
وفق ما افاد مراسل العربيه
بدا اولى خطوته رسميه لاطلاق حملته
الانتخابيه باستدعائه كبار الداعمين
الماليين الى ميامي الاسبوع المقبل كما
وقع خلال الشهور الماضيه على تدابير
لاصلاح قوانين الانتخابات وتمكين طلاب
المدارس من تحصيل قسائم يمولها دافعوا
الضرائب للتعليم الخاص فضلا عن توسيع
عقوبه الاعدام لتشمل مختصبين الاطفال
وهكذا يضاف ديسانتس الى قائمه من المرشحين
رسميا للانتخابات تشمل جو بايدن دونالد
ترامب نيكي هيلي وتيمسكوت واسا هاتشنسن
وماي وكريستي
اذا نبقى في اخبار امريكا التقدم بالسن
والتلعثم ورقتان يداوم على اللعب بهما
منتقدون رئيس امريكي جو بايدن لترمى على
طاوله الترشح لانتخابات الرئاسيه كل حين
لكن الورقتين محروقتان حتى اللحظه
فاستطلاعات رايي اظهرت تقدم بايدن على
ترامب ب 44% مقابل 38 في المئه اما ميزه
هذا التقدم لبايدن على خصمه الجمهوري فردت
للناخبين المستقلين اي داعمين لمواقفه من
الاجهاض والعنف باستخدام السلاح لكن قضيه
المهاجرين الذين يعبرون الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قادمين من المكسيك تحمل
ايضا خطرا محتملا على رئيس بعد ان رفع
ادارته للبند الثاني والاربعين حيث فضل
64% من الديمقراطيين و93 من الجمهوريين
مرشحا رئاسيا يدعم اجراءات اكثر صرامه
لتامين الحدود الاستطلاع نفسه اظهر تقدم
ترامب على ديسانتس الذي يتوقع ان يعلن
ترشيحه الاسبوع المقبل بفارق واسع اي 49%
مقابل 21 في المئه لكن للمفارقه كان
بابداء نسبه عاليه من المستطلعين عدم
سعادتهم اصلا بمرشحي الطرفين وفضل اذا 15%
منهم التصويت لمرشح اخر فيما امتنع تسعه
في المئه عن التصويت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا تحديات كثيره سيواجهها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مع اقتراب موعد
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله حيث ان رهانا
حل ازمه سقف الدين التي يمكن ان تؤثر ايضا
على حجم الانفاق العسكري ستكون بمثابه
الورقه الرابحه لرئيس الامريكي الحالي كما
يقول مراقبون
معركه التصريحات والاجراءات المضاده
تتواصل بين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
والحزب الجمهوري قبيل موعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله التي ستشكل حدا فاصلا في
مستقبل بايدن السياسيه رفع سقف الدين
العام يضم الى قائمه طويله من اسباب
الصراع الحاصل بين الرئيس الامريكي
والجمهوريين في مجلس النواب والذي سيحمل
معه تداعيات صعبه سترهق كاهل الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه مع تحوله لاداه سياسيه
تعزز الانقسامات الايديولوجيه بين الحزبين
وتساهم بالدرجه الاولى في زعزعه مكانه
بايدن الذي لم يتمكن لحد الان من مواجهه
الازمات المتتاليه التي تمر بها البلاد
ابرزها جائحه كورونا وفق مراقبين بايدن
اليوم امام مازق سياسي معقد وضروره ايجاد
حل يرضي جميع الاطراف هو الحل الوحيد لتدا
الموقف وكسب رهان التاييد الشعبي خصوصا
وان شعبيته تراجعت في الفتره الاخيره غير
ان هذا الحل مرتبط بالطرق التي سيتم
اعتمادها للتخفيف من الانفاق ورفع سقف
الدين طرق يتم بموجبها قبول البيت الابيض
بوضع حدود للانفاق الفيدرالي وفرض قيود
على الاعانات الاجتماعيه وهو ما سيؤثر في
سياق المتصل على حجم الانفاق العسكري
الامريكي وايضا تاثر العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه التي تعتبر فيها بكين اكبر دائن
التشققات في هذه العلاقه ستتعمق في حال
التوقف عن سداد الديون الامريكيه وستدفع
الصين الى تعزيز موقعها في مجموعه البريكس
فضروره تمرير مشروع قانون يحظى بتاييد
الحزبين بات امرا ملحن وفق تصريحات زعيم
الاغلبيه المطلقه في مجلس الشيوخ لتجنب
خسائر فادحه ستواجهها اسواق المال الامريك
يه والعالميه
التاسع هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
جاكارتا تغرق واندونيسيا تبحث نقل العاصمه
[موسيقى]
مستمرون معكم في التاسعه هذا المساء اعلن
الامين العام لحل في شمال الاطلسي يانس
سولتنبرغ بان تسليم المقاتلات الغربيه الى
كيف سيكون على طاوله اجتماع وزراء دفاع
النيتو في يونيو المقبل وقال بان بولنداس
لوفاكيا قامت بتسليم طائرات مقاتله من
طراز ميك 29 مسبقا الى اوكرانيا كما اشار
السولتنبرغ الى ان توفير منصات الاسلحه لا
يقل اهميه عن صيانتها
المكاسب الاوكرانيه في بخموت على قلتها
تحولت بالفعل الى زخم جديد لترسخ وصفه
للمدينه بقلعه معنويات الاوكرانيين
فالجنود الاوكرانيون اصبحوا للمره الاولى
منذ شهور في موقع المهاجم وليس الدفاع هذا
الزحف لنحو كيلومترين وفر دفعه معنويه
كبيره لاوكرانيا وفي الوقت نفسه ضربه
لروسيا التي امضت ما يقارب العام في
محاولتها لتطويق قاده اوكرانيون ابدوا
املاهم في الاستفاده من دروس معارك بخموت
عند محاوله الهجوم في اماكن اخرى على طول
خط الجبهه البالغ نحو 1000 كم يريد هؤلاء
ابقاء قوه الروسيه كبيره مقيده في بخمت
وما حولها ما يمنع اعاده انتشاره في مناطق
اخرى ويساعد على اختراق خطوطها العميقه
والمحصنه عبر اوكرانيا وفيما القتال مستمر
بشراسه داخل بخموت التي تسيطر روسيا على
الجزء الاكبر منها كانت كشفت المكاسب
الاوكرانيه الاخيره نقاط ضعف روسيه اساسيه
كنقص التنسيق بين تشكيله المنتظمه ووحدات
فاجنر وضعف التواصل وروح المعنويه كما
تقول صحيفه نيويورك تايمز نذهب اذا الى
كيف ومعنى من هناك حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه حذيفه اهلا بك معنا في التاسع هذا
المساء اذا كان الرئيس الاوكرانيه
للاوكرانيين فهل التطورات الميدانيه
تشيي لصالحهم حتى الساعه
مساء الخير نادين اذا لاحظنا في اخر اسبوع
هنالك تقدم مستمر للقوات الاوكرانيه في
حوالي قبل يعني منذ اسبوع وحتى قبل ثلاثه
ايام كانت تقدم كبير استطاعت القوات
الاوكرانيه ان تستعيد 20 كيلومترا في
المناطق مختلفه في جبهه باخموت بالامس لم
يكن استثناء واستطاعت ان تتقدم 500 متر
اما اليوم فالتقدم في في نطاق عريض نعم في
العمق قد يكون ليس كبير ولكن في نطاق واسع
وعريض جدا استطاعت ان تتقدم القوات في
مواقع مختلفه بشكل عام في جبهه وهنا لا
اتحدث عن مدينه باقمت وانما عن جبهه باخمت
بكل قراها ومدنها في هذه المنطقه استطاعت
القوات الاوكرانيه ان تتقدم في بعض النقاط
150 مترا وفي نقاط اخرى 1700 متر اما في
الضواحي الغربيه تحديدا اللواء الثالث
منفصل للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه البريه
استطاع ان يتقدم في جبه ه عرضها 2000
كيلومتر وفي العمق تقدم 700 متر هذا في
خلال هذا النهار اليوم طيب حذيفه مراقبون
عسكريون يعتبرون ان السيطره على بخموت هي
رمزيه بالنسبه للروس اكثر منها استراتيجيه
ماذا بالنسبه للاوكران
بالنسبه للاوكرانيا هي استراتيجيه بنسبه
100% فالعتاده الروسي والقوات الروسيه
المتكدسه في هذه الجبهه وايضا هزيمه
النفسيه للقوات الروسيه التي لم تستطع على
مدى عشره اشهر ان تسيطر على مدينه صغيره
جدا هذه بالنسبه لهم هدف استراتيجي كبير
جدا وكذلك تدمير اكبر قوه عسكريه للقوات
الروسيه التي تركز في هذه الجبهه هذا ايضا
هدف استراتيجي وهذا ما اعلنت عنه كيف منذ
البدايه كذلك امساك الجبهه بان لا تتوسع
الجبهه في مناطق اخرى بعد ان فشلت القوات
الروسيه في السيطره على هذه المدينه
واضطرت الى سحب قوات وعتاد من جبهات اخرى
الى هذه الجبهه لكي تستطيع احكام سيطرتها
عليها هذا ايضا من الاهداف التي تحققها في
هذه الجبهه ومنذ عشره اشهر كامله طيب
حذيفه القصف كان على اشده هذا الصباح وكان
محور القصف وعنوان للتطورات الاوكرانيه
والحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ما التطورات
والتفاصيل حتى الساعه
صحيح نادين طبعا العاصمه كيف استطاعت قوات
الدفاع الجوي ان تسقط جميع الصواريخ التي
اطلقت في تجاه العاصمه عدا بعض الشظائع
التي سقطت في منطقه وفي بعض المناطق
الاخرى دون ان تسبب اي اضرار ولكن في
مخارج خركيف تحديدا في سيركولي هذه القريه
التي كان فيها الروس طبعا لفتره طويله جدا
واستطاعت القوات الروسيه الاوكرانيه عفوا
في هجومها المضاد ان تستعيدها وتستعيد
كثير من الاراضي اليوم كان هنالك قصف وقتل
شخص في هذه القريه كذلك في خرسون كان
هنالك قصف قتل طفل وفي ايضا كان هنالك
قصفا قصف اغلبه تمركز في الجبهه الشرقيه
وكذلك في الجهه الجنوبيه من البلاد
بالاضافه الى خركيف ولايه خركيف شكرا
جزيلا لك من كيف حذيفه عدل مراسل العربيه
الاستخفاف الروسيه بدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه خلال الاشهر الاولى من الحرب
تحول مؤخرا الى ارتباك وحيره حول قوتها
فرغم اشتداد كثافه الهجمات الصاروخيه
الروسيه في الفتره الاخيره الا ان
اوكرانيا اكدت ان هذه الهجمات لم تصب
اهدافها اما السر في تحول الدفاعات جويه
الاوكرانيه الى قوه حصينه غير قابله
للاختراق فيكمن بطبيعه الحال بمزيج من
الاسلحه الغربيه وبمقدمتها الامريكيه كما
تقول شبكه سي ان ان نجاح قوه الرد على
الاوكرانيه يعود اولا لنشر منظومه باتريوت
الامريكيه خاصه في منطقه العاصمه كييف
انظمه قادره على ضرب الطائرات على
ارتفاعات عاليه ومتوسطه حتى كما حقق
النظام الامريكي حيث نجح وصلت الى 100%
وفقا لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
الخزانات الاوكرانيه اذا عجت كذلك بصواريخ
كروز وبعض الصواريخ الباليسيه وصواريخ
الدفاع الجوي قصيره ومت وسطه المدى كانت
قدمتها دول النيتو الاخرى كبطاريات
الالمانيه ايرستيل هذا المزيج اذا ساهمت
فيه اسلحه تمتلكها اوكرانيا اصلا من
الحقبه السوفيتيه ونجحت بنسبه 80% في صد
الهجمات ومنها صواريخ اس 300
[موسيقى]
لاختراق التحصينات الاوكرانيه المتزايده
اعلنت روسيا عن صاروخ من طراز جديد سيدخل
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا صاروخ براني
بوشك الجوي الفائق القدره بحسب وصف نائب
مدير عام شركه اخماش الروسيه الكسندر
كوتشين هو مخصص لتستخدمه طائرات حربيه مثل
وغيرها من الطائرات والمروحيات الحربيه
المزوده بمنصات الصواريخ الجويه غير
الموجهه الصاروخ الجديد سينضم الى اسره
الصواريخ اس 8 عيار 80 ملي مترا فقدره
براني بوشك تتقدم على قدره سابقيه من هذه
الفئه الصاروخيه بمقدار خمسه الى سته
اضعاف يستطيع عبراني بوشك اختراق الحواجز
الخرسانيه وتدمير المنشات الدفاعيه
المحصنه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ابح ابحاث علماء صواريخ روسيه التي تفوق
سرعتها سرعه الصوت قد تنهار وفق رساله
تحذيريه ارسلوها اما السبب فيعودوا لاجهزه
الامن الروسيه التي اعتقلت الكثير من
هؤلاء العلماء بتهمه الخيانه ما قد يوقف
العمل في مركز الابحاث في سيبيريا مثلا في
الرساله المفتوحه المنشوره على الموقع
الالكتروني لمعهد الميكانيكا النظريه
والتطبيقيه حث العلماء الحكومه والشعب
الروسي على انقاذ عقود من عمل العلماء
السوفييت والروس من الانهيار الوشيك اهم
من تم اعتقالهم وفقا المعهد
ناتولي مسلوب وهو فيزيائي متخصص في
ديناميكا الهوائيه ويبلغ من العمر 76 عاما
ولدينا ايضا الاكزاندر شيبليك رئيس مختبر
تكنولوجيا الصواريخ الفائقه السرعه وهو
يبلغ من العمر 56 عاما ونذهب ايضا الى
عالم ديناميكا الهوائيه الثالث فاليري
وكان اعتقل الشهر الماضي هؤلاء العلماء
وصفهم اولائهم بالعباقره ومن شان كفاءاتهم
وسمعتهم المهنيه ان تسمح لهم بالعثور على
وظائف مرموقه وذات اجور جيده في الخارج ان
ارادوا ذلك
[موسيقى]
الصين التي طرحت نفسها كوسيطا في الازمه
الاوكرانيه اكدت عدم القدره على ايجاد
المعجزات او حل سري لانهاء النزاع المبعوث
الصيني الخاص لاوكرانيا كرر دعوته الى
كييف وموسكو لبدء محادثات من اجل وقف
الحرب لافت الى ضروره مبادره كل الاطراف
من تلقاء نفسها لبناء الثقه المتبادله
وتهيئه الظروف لوقف القتال والتحاور وشدد
المبعوث الصيني خلال محادثاته مع
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين على مواصله الصين
تقديم المساعده لاوكرانيا ضمن قدراتها من
جاتها كد وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني عدم
قبول اي مقترحات تعني خساره الاراضي لصالح
روسيا اذكروا ان المبعوث الصيني لهوي هو
اعلى مسؤول صينيه زورو اوكرانيا منذ بدء
الغاز الروسي الذي ترفض بكين ادانته حتى
هذه اللحظه
[موسيقى]
بعض دول تغير مقرات عواصمها احيانا لتنقل
قرار سياسي الى اكثر مناطقها شهره او
لاسباب اقتصاديه وجغرافيه او حتى بسبب
الازدحام المروري غير ان اندونيسيا
الواقعه جنوب شرقي اسيا مجبره على فعل ذلك
بسبب غرق العاصمه الحاليه
تدريجيا جاكرتا صاخبه مشكلاتها كثيره
الاقتضاض اولها حيث يعيش نحو 10 ملايين
شخص في مساحه لا تتجاوز 660 كيلومتر مربعا
يعيش ضعفهم اي 20 مليون اخرين بالمنطقه
المحيطه بالعاصمه حاجه سكان جاكارتا
للمياه النظيفه تدخل ضمن المشاكل الاكبر
فقيامهم بحفر الاف الابار غير القانونيه
جعل الاراضي اقل استقرارا كما ان بحر جاوا
المحيط بالعاصمه بدا يرتفع تدريجيا بسبب
ذوبان الجريد القطبي العائد للتغيرات
المناخيه اذا عوامل اجتمعت الى مدينه يقع
40% منها تحت مستوى سطح البحر باتت تغرق
بما يعادل نحو قدم واحد كل عام اذا مهمه
الانقاذ المستحيله اوجدت خططا لتخفيف
الضغط عن عاصمه البلاد تتمثل ببناء عاصمه
اخرى هذه العاصمه
تارا العاصمه التي تبنى حاليا على اراضي
كانت خاليه بالكامل في مورينيو تقع على
بعد حوالي 1300 كم من العاصمه الحاليه
الرئيس الاندونيسي او وعد بان افتتاح
العاصمه الجديده سيتم العام المقبل وانها
ستكون نموذجا للتحديث البيئي ومحايده
كربونيا خلال عقود قليله
[موسيقى]
وقع حاكم ولايه مونتانا تشريعا يحضر تطبيق
التواصل الاجتماعي تيك توك لتصبح بذلك
مونتانا اول ولايه امريكيه تحضر التطبيق
الصيني بالكامل حكموا مونتانا اكد ان حظر
التطبيق يهدف الى حمايه البيانات الشخصيه
والخاصه لقاتني مونتانا من الحزب الشيوعي
الصيني كما يمنع القانون متاجر التطبيقات
الهواتف المحموله من توفيره داخل الولايه
مع فرض غرامه قدرها 10,000 دولار على
مقدمي تطبيق عن كل يوم تتاح فيه هذه
المنصه
[موسيقى]
بلغت قيمه السوق العملات المشفره بحلول
نهايه عام 2021 نحو ثلاثه تريلونات دولار
مقارنه ب 250 مليون في مطلع عام20 لكن هذا
الصعود الصاروخي تبعه سقوط مدول يصل الى
واحد فاصله ثلاثه تريليون دولار في الوقت
الحالي مجله ايكونوميست ارجعت انحدار
صناعه العملات المشفره الى تدني ثقه الراي
العام خصوصا معا انهيار بورصه العملات
المشفره
الماضي صناعه العملات المشفره تشهد حاله
استقطاب كبيره البعض يرى ان الوعود بانها
ستحدث ثوره في القطاع المالي قد تحطمت لكن
لا يزال هناك امل في تلك الصناعه اذ زاد
سعر عمله بيتكوين بنسبه 70% تقريبا هذا
العام شملت زياده في عقاب انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي اما بنك فقال الشهر الماضي
ان بيتكوين قد تصل الى مئه الف دولار
بحلول نهايه عام 20 24 وانما يطلق عليه
الشتاء العملات المشفره انتهى تقول
ايكونوميس ان العملات المشفره تكسب ارضا
في الدول الضعيفه التي تعاني من تضخم وضعف
العمله مثل الارجنتين ونيجيريا في الخامس
من يناير كان اعلن المنظمون الامريكيون
وبينهم الاحتياطي الفيدرالي ان الاصول
المشفره على الشبكات اللامركزيه ليس تحت
سيطره سلطه مركزيه وتتعارض مع الممارسات
البنكيه بطبيعه الحال لكن هنا يبرز سؤال
الاهم ما الذي سيميز العملات المشفره لو
تم تطبيق الاجراءات المنظمه للشركات
الماليه العاديه
[موسيقى]
حين الاحساس بالغضب او التوتر الكلمه
الاكثر شيوعا هي ارتفاع الضغط اي عدم
القدره على التحمل اكثر لكن بالفعل ارتفاع
ضغط الدم هو مرض خطير يتسلل خفيه احيانا
لدرجه عدم معرفه الاصابه به فمنظمه الصحه
العالميه قدرت عدد المصابين بارتفاع ضغط
الدم حول العالم بمليار و280 مليون شخص
غير ان
46% من ضحاياه يجهلون الاصابه بهم يعد ضغط
الدم خطرا ان ترك دون علاج اي عند ارتفاعه
في الاوعيه الدمويه الى 90 على 140 ملم
زئبقيا او حتى اكثر من ذلك حينها تكون قوه
دفع الدم باتجاه جدران الشرايين عاليه
للغايه باستمرار ما يجهد القلب اكثر خلال
ضخ الدم وبالتالي يستوجب الرعايه الطبيه
الطارئه العوامل المسببه بعضها قابل
للتغيير كنظام غذائي وصحي واخرى لا يمكن
تغييرها
كعامل الوراثه اي السوابق العائليه وتجاوز
سن الخامسه وستين عاما
[موسيقى]
على كل حال بعد الفاصل سننتقل الى جده
وتغطيه مستمره على العربيه زميله رشا نبيل
وظيفه السياسي المصري مصطفى الفقي لمتابعه
مجريات المتعلقه بالقمه العربيه ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
مستمرون معكم في التاسعه هذا المساء عوده
سوريا الى المشهد العربي والاقتتال في
السودان والعديد من الملفات والقضايا
تستعد القمه العربيه الثانيه في جده
لمناقشتها عبد الرحمن العصيمي رصد لنا
ابرزها في هذا التقرير نتابع
ملفات ساخنه وتحديات عده تواجه القمه
العربيه الثانيه 32 في مدينه جده التي
تاتي في ظل ظروف امنيه معقده تمر بها
المنطقه العربيه والعالميه على حد سواء ما
ابرزوا هذه الملفات ملف الازمه السودانيه
من ابرز الملفات المطروحه على طاوله القمه
العربيه وسط توقعات بتحرك عربي واسع
لانهاء حاله الاقتتال استكمالا للدوري
السعودي القائم حاليا عمليه السلام في
اليمن واتمامها ستكون من اولويات القمه
العربيه حيث من المتوقع ان يكون هناك دعم
عربي للتوافق اليمني المنبثقي من الاتفاق
السعودي اليمني لتحقيق الاستقرار الدائم
في البلاد ايضا من ابرز ملفات المطروحه في
قمه جده عوده سوريا الى الحضن العربي
وتعزيز
دمجها في المشهد العربي عبر اطلاق مبادرات
وتوصيات مرتقبه في بيان القمه الختامي
الامن الغذائي هو الاخر يعتبر من الملفات
المشتركه على اجنده القمه العربيه ما
يستدعي ضروره تحقيق السله الغذائيه
الواحده التي تحقق الاكتفاء الذاتي للعرب
بحسب الخبراء الامن المائي كذلك ياتي ضمن
ابرز ملفات قمه جدا لا سيما في ظل
النزاعات الاقليميه الراهنه سواء مرتبطه
في السودان ومصر مع اثيوبيا او في سوريا
والعراق مع تركيا ملفات اخرى سيناقشها
الزعماء العرب في قمتهم 32 الاوضاع
السياسيه في ليبيا ودعم الجهود لتحديد
موعد للانتخابات بالاضافه الى النهوض
بالعمل العربي المشترك ووضع اليه الزاميه
لتطبيق ومتابعه مخرجات قرارات القمه
العربيه
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مدينه جده العربيه
[موسيقى]
نبقى في اجواء اخبار القمه العربيه
الثانيه والثلاثين والتي من المقرر عقدها
في جده السعوديه يوم غد قناه العربيه طبعا
ستخصص تغطيه خاصه في هذا الخصوص سواء من
استديوهات العربيه الخارجيه في جده وايضا
استوديوهاتنا طبعا نكون معكم في تغطيه
خاصه ننقل لكم الصور والمشاهد اولا باول
في حال ورودها كنا نتابع طوال هذا اليوم
لتغطيه وصول القاده العرب للمشاركه في
القمه العربيه طبعا وفق مراسله العربيه ان
توافد وصول القاده العرب سيكون حتى يوم غد
حتى صباح يوم غد اذا قبل ساعات من انعقاد
القمه التي من المقرر ان تبدا في توقيت
تقريبا الواحده بعد الظهر كما يقول مراسله
العربيه المتواجدون هناك سواء من المركز
الاعلامي في جده حيث مقر انعقاد قمه وايضا
في الاستديوهات الخارجيه حيث خصصنا
استديوهات خارجيه من قلب الحدث لتغطيه
جديد الاخبار مع ضيوف العربيه كنا طبعا
ننقل لكم كل هذه الصور وابرز المشاهد التي
وصلت هذا اليوم لصور وصول الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد حيث ان هذه هي المشاركه
العربيه السوريه الاولى منذ 12 عاما
لسوريا بعد تجميد عضويتها بالجامعه
العربيه في عام 2011 على خلفيه اندلاع
الحرب السوريه طبعا هذه القمه تعقد وسط
ظروف استثنائيه اذا تمر بها المنطقه
والعالم وتحديدا عالمنا العربي في ظل
الحديث عن تصفير الازمات في المنطقه كما
اكداها مرارا ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان على كل حال ننتقل الى جده
الان وهذه التغطيه المباشره
للقمه الثانيه والعشرين ونذهب الى 32 اذا
لنذهب الى استوديو العربيه الخارجي مع
زميلتنا رشا نبيل رشا يسعد مساكم تغطيه
مستمره معكم انتم متواجدون لتقربوا لنا
الصوره والحدث اكثر ومع العربيه ان تعرف
اكثر تفضلي يا رشا
شكرا لك نادين وتغطيه مستمره على شاشه
العربيه اذ يواصلوا زعماء وقاده الدول
العربيه التوافد الى جده التي تحتضن القمه
الثانيه 32 حيث وصل رئيس السوري بشار
الاسد الذي يتراسه وفد بلاده بعد عوده
سوريا لمقعدها العربي لتنهي بذلك عزلتها
مع الجامعه والتي استمرت 12 عاما ترقب
واسع لهذه القمه وما ستحمله من نتائج
خصوصا في قضيتي السودان وسوريا
[موسيقى]
بين اولى خطوات التاسيس لجامعه الدول
العربيه وعوده سوريا اليها بعد تجميد طويل
للعضويه ثمانيه عقود مرت فيها سوريا بتقلب
العلاقات مع الجامعه
تاريخيا سوريا كانت من اوائل الدول التي
شاركت بتمثيل قوي في الجامعه العربيه بعد
دعوه مصطفى النحاس رئيس الوزراء المصري
لنظيره السوري جميل مردنبك الى القاهره
لمناقشه انشاء تحالف عربي عام
1944 وتكون سوريا ضمن الدول السبع الموقعه
البروتوكول الاسكندريه
تزامنت قمه الجامعه عام
1967 في الخرطوم وحربي يونيو حيث خسرت
سوريا مناطق ابرزها الجولان في الحرب مع
اسرائيل وسميت بقمه اللات ثلاث لا صلح لا
تفاوض ولا اعتراف باسرائيل شاركت فيها
كافه الدول العربيه باستثناء سوريا التي
دعت الى حرب تحرير شعبيه
بيان ختامي صدر عن القمه العربيه في
نوفمبر
1973 في الجزائر التي انعقدت بمبادره
سوريه مصريه يقضي بتقديم الدعم المالي
والعسكري لسوريا ومصر بعد شنهما حرب
اكتوبر على اسرائيل لاسترداد الاراضي التي
خسيرتها في حرب 1967
قمه مايو 1990 في بغداد غابت عنها سوريا
اثر الخلافات السياسيه بين دمشق وبغداد
لكنها عادت للحضور الى القمه الطارئه في
اغسطس من نفس العام في القاهره على خلفيه
غزو العراق للكويت لتدين الحرب وتتضامن مع
الدول الخليج في المطالبه باخراج القوات
العراقيه من الكويت
اما اخر القمم التي برز فيها اسم سوريا
كانت في نوفمبر 2011 بعد ان اجمع القاده
العرب على تجميد عضويه دمشق على خلفيه رد
فعلها على الحراك الشعبي في البلاد اذا
عمر العربيه
عنوان رئيس في هذه القمه وهو عوده سوريا
الى الجامعه العربيه ولكن ايضا تحديات
كبيره تواجه هذه القمه تتعلق باسراع
المسلح في السودان بالاضافه الى التواتر
المتصاعد في الاراضي المحتله اضافه الى
الازمات الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها العديد
من الدول العربيه ينضم الينا في هذا الجزء
من التغطيه في الاستوديو عضو مجلس الشيوخ
المصريه دكتور عبد المنعم سعيد مرحبا بك
دكتور ربما العنوان في كل وسائل الاعلامي
يركز بشكل كبير جدا على عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه هذه العوده دكتور فيما
يتعلق بالازمه السوريه ككل هل نحن نقطع
مسافه كبيره ام ان هناك تحديات ما زالت
تواجه هذه المساله
مسافه كبيره لازم ايه نقطه القياس يعني لو
نقطه القياس هي الربيع العربي اللي حصل في
سوريا كان بدايه ازمه كبيره
وترجمتها حرب اهليه والشكل اللي احنا
شايفينه دلوقتي طبعا نقدر نقول ان في فرق
يعني لان سوريا الان اكثر تماسك دخولها
الجامعه العربيه مره اخرى فيها نوع من من
الشرعيه لكن لو احنا واخدين نقطه القياس
سوريا كدوله لها تاريخ ولا مكانه في
العالم العربي يعني طبعا هي بتيجي وتدخل
الجامعه العربيه وهي مجروحه
ولذلك هنجد جزء من الامور المتداوله
المتعلقه بالعوده انه قالوا الاول هيبقى
كل خطوه قدامنا خطوه الامين العامري جامعه
الدول العربيه السفير احمد ابو الغيط
اتكلم على انه قضيه اللاجئين هتبقى مرتبطه
بقضيه الاعمار فادا تعتبر نقطه كبيره
وتتحط في اطار تاني شويه هو اطار انا
بسميه دايما الاقليميه الجديده في المنطقه
اللي هي بدات باعلان العلا في خمسه يناير
71 اللي ودعها الى التهدئه انتهاء فكره
التحالف العربي ضد قطر وتركيا الاستقطاب
اللي كان احد نتائج الربيع المزعوم انما
الحته هي انه
الحزمه كلها على بعض بتتغير من اول علاقات
مع ايران مع تركيا همم كانت اتغيرت باشكال
جديده شويه ومفاجئه مع اسرائيل من خلال
السلام الابراهيمي لكن الشعور العام ان
فتره
السخونه والحروب الاهليه
والصراعات الجيو السياسيه وجيو استراتيجيه
بتهدا بتفتح مجالات وقنوات للحديث من هنا
يمكن
امام علم عربي اقل حده في مشاكله في
توتراته في صراعاته دلوقتي يعني انا بتكلم
باخد حاجه يعني نتيجه الثمن الفادح اللي
اتدفع للمرحله اللي قبل كده في نوايا
موجوده نحو انه هذا التمن اولا يتوقف عن
الاستنزاف وبعد ذلك نبتدي في عمليه يعني
استعاده
القوه يعني
هو فيها جزء كمان انه يعني يمكن انا مره
قلتها في الامارات حتى في مؤتمر للعرب
يعني
لازم نبقى احنا عارفين كويس انه الخروج
الامريكي من المنطقه
روسيا بقت اكبر من معين يعني بقت قوه
احتلال اوعاد
اللي موجود في سوريا انه
الزهور الصيني اللي ارتبط بالذات بقوه مع
مع ازمه الكورونا وبعدها ازمه اوكرانيا ده
خلقت
او بيئه موجوده للعالم العربي يقدر يتصرف
فيها من خلال عدد من الامور لها علاقه
بالاصلاح الداخلي لها علاقه بفكره الدوله
الوطنيه اللي فيها علاقه حوالين العلاقات
العربيه العربيه
مش محطوطه في لحاف ايديولوجي او رداء
ايديول
بشكل خ
فيفا العربيه او في الاجندات العربيه لكل
دوله وهناك عدد من الصراعات يدفع ثمن لهذه
الاجندات المختلفه هذا ربما لا ينطبق على
سوريا فقط ولكن ينسحب ايضا على السودان
الان هل فكره العمل العربي المشتركه
الموحد هذه الافكار التي كان يتم طرددها
هي قابله للتطبيق في ظل هذا التباين في
قامت على فكره ان احنا عرب اولا ما احناش
مصريين وسوريين ولبنانيين والى اخره دي
كانت فكره شويه فيها كثير من لطيفه
وحماسيه انما عمليا انها فكره الخلافات ده
الامر الطبيعي يعني شوفي في اتحاد اوروبي
ومع ذلك المانيا مش فرنسا والاثنين ما
هماش ايطاليا والى اخره دائما لان
الجغرافيا السياسيه بتاعت كل دوله مختلفه
فانا في طبعا خلافات بس مش هم وانا من
المؤمنين بكده كل الدول اللي فيها ازمات
مزمنه زي لسه سوريا اليمن السودان ده شغل
السودانيين
والسوريين واليمنيين في الاساس القوه
الخارجيه سواء اقليميه عربيه او اقليميه
غير عربيه او قوه دوليه مختلفه من الطبيعي
اول ما تلاقي في نقطه التهاب بتبقى عامله
زي الجسم لما بيحصل له التهاب في حته
معينه تلاقي كل الكرات الدم البيضاء
والحمراء وكله بيروحوا على مكان الالتهاب
فهو
الموضوع ده
يعني هو مترتب على وجود مرض داخلي
اللي بقوله هنا ايه ادراك ذلك مهم لانه ده
اللي هيخلينا نقيس بقى فكره الخلافات لانه
ببساطه احنا كلنا مش جغرافيا واحده كلنا
مش لون واحد كلنا مش عدد سكان واحد كلنا
علاقاتنا بالموارد الاوليه نفط وغاز وغيره
مش من نفس الطريقه
تحييد الاطراف الاقليميه او الدوليه في اي
صراع من الصراعات الموجوده في المنطقه
تبدو فكره ليست سهله دكتور ولكن دعونا
نذكر بتصريحات الامين العامه لجامعه الدول
العربيه السفير احمد ابو الغيط الذي اكد
ان قرار اعاده سوريا الى الحضن العربي لا
يعني استئناف العلاقات بين جميع الدول
العربيه وسوريا لان الامر متروك لكل دوله
على حدى وفقا لرؤيتها
النهارده سوريا
عضو كامل العضويه له كل الصلاحيات وكل
الحقوق وكل الواجبات على
الدوله العظم طبعا هذه العوده
لا تفرض على الدول اعضاء الجامعه نهجم
معين تجاه
الحكومه السوريه هي عاده
بتوافق من الجميع
هناك من سوف يعيد علاقات وهناك من سوف
يتحفظ في اعاده العلاقات هذا امر خاص
بزياده كل دوله لكن عضويتها كامله
واعتقد انها
سببت
غضب لدى اعداء الحكم في سوريا في العالم
الغربي اساسا
ويبقى معنا دكتور عبد المنعم سعيد
سعيدا من دمشق الكاتب الصحفي عبد الحميد
توفيق مرحبا بك استاذ عبد الحميد الحديث
يتمحور حول سوريا بشكل كبير ولكن
التاكيدات تقول ان سوريا عادت الى الجامعه
ولكن ما زالت الازمه السوريه قائمه كيف
ستتعامل سوريا مع هذه المعطيات الجديده
خاصه ان الجماعه العربيه وضعت قاعده وهي
خطوه مقابله خطوه
مساء الخير لحضرتك ولضيفك الكريم والساده
المشاهدين من الواضح بان هذه الخارطه
الطريق التي وضعت واقرت في اجتماع جده ثم
اجتماعي عمان الخماسي لوزراء الخارجيه
اعطت الكثير من الامل بان يكون هناك خطوه
اولى نحو بدء الحل في سوريا سوريا نعم
عادت اليوم الى الجامعه العربيه هدم هذا
السوره النفسي والسياسي بين سوريا وبين
الحاضنه العربيه عموما وايضا تمكنت هذه
الرباعيه العربيه التي اعتقد بانها هي
الاكثر قدره على اداره شؤون الملف السوري
ما بعد قمه جده لوصولا الى وصول الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد لاول مره منذ تقريبا
الى ان يكون في على كرسيه الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه كرئيس
[موسيقى]
بالتالي
اعتقد بان
هذه المساله باتت محصوره في
اتجاهين الاتجاه الاول هو كيف سيتفاعل
الجانب السوري مع
الوقائع وبنود خارطه الطريق العربيه ويبدو
من اللحظه الاولى بان تفاعل السوري ايجابي
وكيف سيكون العرب
قادرين على تطبيق مبدا الخطوه مقابل
الخطوه اتوقع بان تكون هذه العوده هي
فارقه الامل
وضع خارطه طريق الحل للشان السوري ووضع
السوري على سكه سكتها الصحيحه وبالتالي
نعم اقول عوده سوريا لا تعني الحل ولكن
دعني الاشاره الى احتماليه ان يكون الحل
قريبا عن طريق الخارطه العربيه التي رسمت
نعم دكتور ابقى معي استاذ عبد الحميد
استاذ عبد الحميد يقول ان الحل سيكون
قريبا وان هناك تفاؤل بهذا الامر وانه
سياتي من تلك البيئه العربيه المحيطه او
الداعمه لسوريا في هذا التوقيت حضرتك كنت
تتحدث عن مساله تحييد ان يكون هناك قرار
سيادي من الدول بتحييد الاطراف الاقليميه
والدوليه المحيطه بالازمات
بالشده اللي انت بتقوليها دي انا بقول انك
انت الاعتماد الاساسي على الدوله ذاتها هل
بتقدر تحيدهم ولا لا بيتوقف على قدرتها
على انها تستغل مواقف معينه تنتهز فرص
معينه او انها لما يجي لها حاجه زي اعاده
الشرعيه للكيان السوري هو ليه سوريا طلعت
من الجامعه العربيه يعني حصل معاها يمكن
اقصى من اللي حصل مع مصر فيما يتعلق
بالخروج من الجامعه العربيه سنبقى دكتور
في هذه التغطيه للاسف الوقت انتهى لكن
التغطيه مستمره وستكون معنا الدكتور غدا
ان شاء الله في فعاليات هذه القمه القمه
العربيه في مدينه جده السعوديه ونعود الان
الى الاستديوهات في دبي ونواصل مع حضراتكم
تقديم خدمتنا الاخباريه ستنضم اليكم
الزميله راوي القاسم
و30 لضيوفك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات